[Music]  at first glance I bet you're wondering  what you're watching but what if I told  you this was a cake and maybe not your  ordinary cake with a 3D jelly art cake  3D jelly art cakes are made with gelatin  or agar agar these clear cakes come in a  range of different colors flavors themes  with flowers being the most popular  early artists create these intricate  designs from the underside of the cake  and technically create the cake upside  down use special steel nozzles and  syringes to insert and layer one color  at a time into the clear gelatin base  colors are usually made from natural  foods like matcha purees or other fruit  that needs to be kept warm during the  process then the cakes are flipped over  to reveal the final design  [Music]  and personally I was blown away with  this Talent follow jeremonies for more  gorgeous cakes